look at it out there it looks calm
doesn't it it's actually swarming with
microscopic life that's like my
grandfather Jacques Cousteau used to say
everyone always talks about fish and
whales let's talk about phytoplankton
they're small it's estimated that in
every teaspoon of sea water
there's about a hundred thousand of them
but you need a microscope to see them
they're the unsung heroes of our ocean
more than half the oxygen in our
atmosphere
is thanks to phytoplankton and today
we'll learn about two types let's talk
about chuckle if fors everyday in the
ocean they're battling viruses and
bacteria and each time they die they
release a little puff of oxygen into the
atmosphere if you were to look down from
space you could see this immense battle
field full of trillions of their dead
ever heard of the White Cliffs of Dover
made up of dead Cocola thefor skeletons
romantic isn't it
and now dinoflagellates these are
responsible for bioluminescent waters or
glowing oceans they're also responsible
for blood red tides when dinoflagellates
bloom they turn the water a deep crimson
red these red tides are dangerous and
responsible for loss of ocean and
possibly human life phytoplankton giveth
and taketh in return